going to bring you some breaking news
now from Pakistan the former prime
minister Imran Khan has taken to social
media he's put this on Twitter he says
probably my last tweet before my next
arrest police have surrounded my house
Imran Khan and currently live streaming
on his YouTube channel he says police
are currently surrounding his house
Imran Khan was granted bail in cases
relating to corruption charges earlier
this week he has said that he believes
there are plans to re-arrest him and he
has been reiterating calls to his
followers to hold peaceful protests
against his arrest but that is Imran
Khan from inside his house we believe
saying that police are surrounding him
ready to re-arrest him in connection
with those corruption charges I will
bring you more on that as we get it here
on Sky News